Pixar's super-family the Incredibles are back
in a long-awaited sequel that's bursting with
easter eggs, references and secret cameos.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the top 30 Pixar,
superhero, and pop culture easter eggs you
might have missed in Incredibles 2 and what
that post-credits teaser means for Incredibles
3.
I'm also starting a new Incredibles giveaway;
you just need to be a subscriber and leave
a comment below about the movie to enter.
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you haven't
seen the film yet.
A113 is a regular Pixar easter egg that's
an homage to the California Institute of the
Arts classroom where many of Pixar's animators
studied, and it pops up multiple times in
Incredibles 2.
It appears on the runaway monorail that Elastigirl
stops.
It's also the number of the room where Elastigirl
watches the Screenslaver's broadcast.
It's also on the side of the hydroliner where
the final act takes place.
And A-1-1-3 also shows up at the movie theatre
at the end of the film and it's sneakily hidden
in the movie posters for Dementia 113.
By the way, the film playing at the movie
theatre is also a reference to an early 1960s
Francis Ford Coppola movie.
Edna Mode and Jack-Jack's scenes are some
of the best parts of the sequel.
When Bob goes to Edna's place where she's
been babysitting Jack-Jack, she tells him
that the super-powered toddler likes Mozart,
which is a nod to Kari the babysitter who
mentioned Mozart in the first movie and also
used his music in the short film, Jack-Jack
Attack.
"I also brought Mozart to play while he sleeps
because leading experts say Mozart makes babies
smarter."
There's a very clever Poltergeist reference
during the Jack-Jack cookie scene.
Craig T. Nelson, who starred in the classic
1982 horror movie and who's also the voice
of Mr Incredible, hears Jack-Jack talking
from another dimension after he disappears
leaving a remote control behind.
"What the..?!"
"Cookie!
Cha cha want a cookie?!"
"Nam nam cookie!"
"Cha cha want num num?"
In Poltergeist, one of Craig T. Nelson's children
gets sucked into another dimension by ghosts
and, similar to Jack-Jack, the family can
hear her voice from the other dimension in
their TV set.
"Where are you?!"
"Mummy!"
The Pizza Planet truck from the first Toy
Story movie is a regular Pixar easter egg
which has appeared in every movie so far,
the only exception being the first Incredibles.
This time around though, a period-styled Pizza
Planet truck was specially designed to fit
the setting of the sequel.
This easter egg was placed by sets supervisor
Nathan Fariss who notoriously made the Pizza
Planet truck in Finding Dory almost impossible
to find.
In Incredibles 2 though the Screenslaver is
revealed as being an ordinary pizza guy so
the Pizza Planet truck is likely in a scene
he appears in.
Another regular easter egg is the Chinese
take-out container.
This style of box has a very specific design
that recurs throughout Pixar's films after
first having appeared in A Bug's Life where
it was called the "Chinese Cabinet of Metamorphosis"
and used by Manny for his circus act.
Another easter egg which supports the Pixar
theory of a shared universe is a billboard
in Incredibles 2 for TripleDent Gum which
is really hard to spot but it flashes by during
the Elastigirl train rescue scene.
TripleDent Gum is the brand of chewing gum
from Inside Out the jingle for which plays
throughout that movie.
"TripleDent gum.
Will make you smile"
"The song from the gum commercial?"
And there was also a TripleDent Gum easter
egg last year in Cars 3 with the brand appearing
as a car sponsor.
The recurring easter eggs of brands like Pizza
Planet and TripleDent Gum, as well as the
same Chinese takeout box design lend support
to the Pixar theory that all their movies
exist within the same universe.
The mind-erasing device that Rick Dicker uses
to make Tony Rydinger forget Violet's secret
identity is the same one he used to erase
Kari's memory of the baby's superpowers in
Jack-Jack Attack.
Incredibles 2, of course, includes lots of
call-backs to moments and details from the
first movie.
When Mr Incredible and Elastigirl go to their
meeting with Devtech, they wear the original
costumes they had before Edna made their iconic
red suits.
And Elastigirl's new silver suit and Elasticycle
both have an upgraded version of the logo
she used to have when she was a solo superheroine.
Designers were strategic when it came to Helen's
multiple supersuits, building one basic suit
and varying the shading and logos to create
three distinct looks.
The strategy required some tweaks to Elastigirl's
original suit, shrinking and moving her logo
so that it fit within the established template.
Elastigirl's darker, sleeker design is meant
to be practical to help sneak around in the
shadows tracking villains, however, when Helen
complains that it's dark and angsty, she's
also commenting on modern superhero movies
which have tended to shy away from bright
colourful costumes.
"I'm not all dark and angsty, I'm Elastigirl."
At the Incredible family's new house, there's
a mug with a logo for Insuricare, Bob's old
employer from the first movie.
The waterfall that Elastigirl drives the Elasticycle
out of is reminiscent of Syndrome's lava waterfall
which also worked as a hidden opening in the
first Incredibles movie.
Plus, I also got some Batcave vibes from this
scene.
And when Elastigirl uses her body as a parachute
to slow down the speeding monorail, it's a
call-back to when she performed a similar
move on the monorail at Syndrome's island
hideout.
The other big regular Pixar easter egg is
the famous Luxo ball.
If you want to spot that in this movie, look
out for Jack-Jack's cradle.
The Luxo ball appeared in Pixar's very first
short film, Luxo Jr, together with two desk
lamps, one of which is still used in Pixar's
logo.
As well as all the Pixar references, there
are also some cool superhero easter eggs and
in-jokes in Incredibles 2.
When Dash says "We wanna fight bad guys!"
"It defines who I am."
It's probably a reference to Christopher Nolan's
Batman origin movie "Batman Begins".
"It's not who I am underneath, but what I
do that defines me."
Some of the visuals in the movie also felt
Batman-esque to me, such as how Elastigirl
looks like she's flying through the city like
a bat, and these rooftop shots of Elastigirl
which reminded me of Frank Miller's The Dark
Knight Returns and also Batman v Superman.
Following Pixar tradition, Incredibles 2 includes
an easter egg to the studio's next movie,
Toy Story 4; however, because details of Toy
Story 4 are still sparse at this point, Incredibles
2 sets supervisor Nathan Fariss has said that
the easter egg will probably only make sense
once Toy Story 4 comes out.
I did spot what looks like a neon cowboy hat
during the helicopter rescue scene, which
could be a Woody easter egg or perhaps a reference
to a new Toy Story character or location.
If you saw anything else, do let me know in
the comments!
The Incredibles 2 credits are a joy to watch,
but if you didn't quite stick around to the
very end then you may have missed a tiny little
teaser for a possible sequel.
It's not a proper post-credits scene like
you might expect from a live-action superhero
movie, but after all the credits have rolled
and just before the screen fades to black,
a little image of the Underminer's drill pops
up again.
This is a reminder that the villain got away
earlier in the movie and that he's still hanging
out underneath Municiberg ready to return
if Pixar want to greenlight an Incredibles
3.
There's also a stack of secret cameos you
might have missed in the film.
Singer-songwriter Usher makes a surprise cameo
in the movie as Frozone's biggest fan and
his words in the sequel are also a call-back
to Syndrome's line to Mr Incredible in the
original movie.
"I'm your number one fan!"
"I mean, after all, I am your biggest fan."
This time around, Rick Dicker is voiced by
Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul actor Jonathan
Banks as Bud Luckey, who previously voiced
the government agent, passed away between
films.
John Ratzenberger, who's voiced a character
in every Pixar movie so far, returns as the
voice of the Underminer.
The sons of Incredibles director Brad Bird
lent their voices to the original movie and
the sequel.
Nick Bird, who was the voice of the tricycle
kid in the first movie, and also voiced Squirt
in Finding Nemo, performed the voice of Monster
Jack-Jack.
And Nick's elder brother, Michael Bird, returned
as the voice of Tony Rydinger, Violet's high-school
crush.
Signage in the movie also provides a place
for loads of secret shout-outs for Pixar crew
members.
This Christov billboard advertising Bulgarian
overalls is a nod to Incredibles 2 art director
and Bulgarian-born Anthony Christov.
Pixar legend Joe Ranft is honoured via the
Joe Ranft Grocery store.
Ranft had an Oscar nomination as one of the
writers on Toy Story, and before passing away
he'd worked on all of Pixar's movies plus
voiced various characters.
Incredibles 2 story manager Kathryn Hendrickson's
name appears on a sign on the side of a building
during the Underminer sequence.
And current Technical Art Director at Pixar,
Michael Rutter, also gets a shout-out via
the "Rutter's Everyday Repair and Replacement"
store in Municiberg.
There's also a Domee's Deli named after Domee
Shi who directed the Pixar short Bao which
plays in front of Incredibles 2.
Now this next one would have been a delicious
easter egg for Incredibles fans everywhere.
"Fifteen years too late."
Incredibles 2 was originally going to be released
in 2019 meaning it would have come out 15
years after the original, making that Syndrome
line fit perfectly.
Pixar though had numerous problems with Toy
Story 4 so the two films' release dates were
switched around, bringing the Incredibles
sequel forward one year – a bitter blow
for lovers of that Syndrome meme.
So, what other easter eggs or references did
you spot?
And did you enjoy the sequel as much as the
original movie?
Be sure to let me know and make sure you're
subscribed for a chance to win an Incredibles
Funko Pop.
You can also tweet me any comments or requests.
Coming up next are more Incredibles 2 videos
plus Jurassic World 2 and I'll link those
here on screen when they're ready.
Congratulations to my last Incredibles giveaway
winner.
Send me an email me from my channel's About
page or tweet me so I can send you the prize.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.